The Keki family has waited for this moment for more than three years.
Finally they can hold their daughter Hauwa in their arms again.
"I'm so happy.
Just happy and grateful to God."
They have a lot of catching-up to do.
Hauwa's parents show her photos of the rest of the family - and she gets to see how everyone's changed.
And then finally Hauwa gets to talk on the
phone with her siblings again.
"They've constantly been asking about her.
No day goes by when they haven't asked me:
'How is she?'
'Does she get enough to eat?'
'Where does she sleep?'
'On a mattress?'
'On leaves from the jungle?'
They really worried a lot about her and always asked about her.
I then tried to calm them down and tell them that everything is okay and that she would
return one day."
Her father hopes that everybody will soon be able to live together again.
"If things remain peaceful now, she can return home.
Why shouldn't she?
She can return home and take her graduation
exam."
But that seems unlikely.
Last October, 23 girls were freed from the
militant group Boko Haram.
The government still has the girls in its care in the capital.
Some parents complain that they hardly get access to their own daughters.
A government spokesperson on Nigerian television offered this explanation.
"Ever since the most important thing for the country is that these girls are a security
interest in the fight against them.
Who knows - among them maybe some of them have returned radicalized.
And releasing them to the mainstream might
pose a danger itself to society."
Boko Haram recently released a video supposedly showing four of the kidnapped girls from Chibok.
In it they pledge loyalty to Boko Haram and refuse to return home.
Observers though are warning against placing
the girls under suspicion.
Instead they say, their families should be
brought in to play a greater role.
"It is not acceptable that they should be
kept away from family, friends and relations
for so long.
I don't see any justification for that.
And the reasons given by government are not sufficient for me."
Hauwa's parents can only guess what she has gone through in the past three years.
All they hope for now, is some peace and quiet - and a return to somewhat of a normal life.